on but there was a lot of sexual
harassment allegations from her staff
specifically her producers where they
were
i guess one of them i think it was a
male producer and i think he's i think
he's uh
lgbt and he he grabbed
somebody's dick or something like that
or some [ __ ] yeah
i'm like yo well how the [ __ ] do you get
away with this stuff you just walk up
and just swipe a dick and then all of a
sudden
hey there buddy how secure in your job
do you have to be to come up grab dick
and be like yeah i'm still going to work
tomorrow yeah
that's [ __ ] nuts to me you never
played off as a joke i got you yeah
that was like sexual advance because i
guess there was some intimidation
tactics too they would
they would kind of treat interns very
unfairly and kind of make them feel that
they're going to lose their job the next
day which isn't very great for
in five four three two one
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain podcast
we got edric in the house yes sir what's
going on
oh okay we were just we just had a we
had a very funny conversation earlier
yeah
can't talk about it here though we can't
but we can talk about it in generalities
i [ __ ] hate some of my friends kids
not anybody that you guys [ __ ] know
because every time i mention a story
it's weird because when we talk about
certain things right
i don't use if i do use names they're
not their actual names right
it just makes it easier for the story's
sake but
every time i tell these stories they go
oh is it bart is it geo
it's like i just met these guys in the
last 10 years there was 24
20 no 20 years before them that i met a
[ __ ] ton of other people also they
aren't my only [ __ ] friends
i think it's just because like they're
so curious about the lives of the people
that they watch or listen to and then
they just they just want to attach a
name to it you know like somebody they
know they want it to be that person yeah
exactly
because i'll tell these like funny
stories or these bad stories about
people why would i tell those stories
specifically about people you guys
already know that doesn't make any sense
it's too easy
yeah let me let me put these dudes on
blast i know these guys that own this
[ __ ] comedy channel let's just call
it
jp films yeah [ __ ] ridiculous
we just had popeyes too amazing by the
way the spicy chicken sandwich yeah
i was like [ __ ] popeyes with uh k
yesterday so the reason why i got popped
by us right now is because when we went
there
uh last night there's a new popeyes over
uh in highland park it's [ __ ] packed
yeah everybody loves that [ __ ] that [ __ ]
was a kfc before nobody went there
turned into a popeye's everybody's there
no for sure
i mean even the one um near essie uh in
l.a
uh i went to get some chicken there a
couple weeks ago
drive through i legit waited like 20
minutes yeah yeah
i was like god damn people really want
the fried chicken man
so when we went there we went to go pick
up a spicy chicken sandwich because i
was craving it
and when we got there there was a sign
that said there's no more fried chicken
sandwiches
oh hell no so there was a guy that was
in front of us in a beamer
he's like a i don't know if he was white
mexican armenian he was one of those
guys
but he was chilling and the guy of
course he has to say this
you could tell the the girl who was in
um
customer service who was taking the
order she was very young just by the
sound of her voice
and she goes hey i'm sorry to let you
know but there's no more um spicy
chicken sandwiches and the person before
us
before you who got there they took all
the last tenders
so i'm really sorry about that and the
guy just starts giving this
young woman some [ __ ] you know this is a
young girl
he goes well you guys well you should
put the sign up earlier before people
get into the drive-through
and she goes oh i'm really sorry blah
blah blah and he says the same thing
again he goes
you should really put that sign up
before people come through and you know
this girl she's a young girl she doesn't
own [ __ ] popeyes [ __ ] she's just an
employee taking your order yeah she's
being extremely apologetic
as she's doing it and he says it one
more time he goes just make sure you
guys put the sign up in front
now i'm getting a little pissed because
he's mistreating this young girl
as if she can do anything about it she
doesn't own popeyes
but i see this dude it's like an older
gentleman in his [ __ ] mercedes with
his [ __ ] younger girlfriend
and i'm getting visibly upset and then
you know khalifa is getting like
a little upset too like the [ __ ] is
wrong with this dude yeah and so as
we're going up there
and you know i kind of joked with the
girl whatever just trying to make her
feel better
and then afterwards she offered us like
hey can i you guys want something like
some biscuits or something that we could
give you on the house
i was like nah it's okay it's cool just
because we were really sweet to her but
after
the drive that i was so [ __ ]
irritated i just kept talking [ __ ]
loud as [ __ ] with my windows now because
i want to [ __ ] this fool in front of me
right now
because i wanted him to hear it yeah and
you know kate could tell i was like
visibly getting upset because he was
giving this young girl crab
for no [ __ ] reason like what are you
gonna do you're gonna beat her up like
you're [ __ ] tough guy like she's a
teenager yeah and so i'm sitting there
and i'm just like i'm like yeah man some
people are [ __ ] [ __ ]
with the windows down and as i'm saying
it i
i forgot that her intercom was still on
oh i'm not talking about you i'm talking
about the guy in front but just kept
saying over and over and the guy rolled
down his window
and he kind of looked at the side side
mirror and i just kept saying it over
and over and over and he just didn't do
anything he was like you're not going to
do anything
[ __ ] that's such a [ __ ] dick yeah i
don't understand why people mistreat
like fast food workers so much bro i got
i got a similar pot pie story so when
the
chicken sandwich first came out um you
know it was crazy right like we were
talking
yeah two hour wait it's three i didn't
have that chicken sandwich
until maybe four or five months after
okay so i think
this was the second wave like i didn't
hit the first wave but the second wave
and then so um me and my girl like we
were headed
towards like the joshua area to do some
like glamping or whatever
and then i was like you know what let's
let's find the popeyes
on the way and then let's let's just see
if because this is kind of like in the
middle of [ __ ] nowhere
so i'm pretty sure the weight's not
going to be as bad
so we we uh look up a popeyes on the map
we get there
and drive through maybe has like 20 cars
but then i look inside and there's maybe
like a line of 15 people
like okay that's not too bad right well
let's just let's just see
how long it takes so we get in line and
then there's a sign immediately that
says
uh all chicken sandwiches order or
chicken sandwich orders will take at
least 45 minutes
damn sounds like but there's not that
many people
in line so i mean i don't understand why
it would take so long so i was like [ __ ]
it i'm gonna roll the dice on it right
and then um there's these two ladies who
were maybe like two
two two or three uh people ahead of me
um
and then they get to the line and
basically the the fast food worker tells
them oh you know it's gonna be a 45 50
minute wait
and then they just start going off on
the girl like oh hell no what would
like what do you mean 45 50 and then
i'm just like dude she doesn't have any
control over yeah you know
like and she's like let me talk to your
manager oh and she was like
both and then both of them were giving
her attitude you know they started tag
teaming her basically let me tell you
something
i already know right off the bat yeah
those [ __ ] were fat as [ __ ]
only [ __ ] i didn't say
anything but i already know yeah you
have to be the fattest [ __ ] person on
earth to ask for management and a
popeyes yeah that's
that's some other fat level [ __ ] i'm
talking about unhealthy fat
yeah no they they definitely were obese
and then uh they the manager comes
up i don't give a [ __ ] i've never asked
for the manager at a fast food
restaurant ever
and the manager comes and he's like uh
you know we apologize we're just
really backed up right and you could
tell man like they're stressed out
slammed yeah
because they're going they have to do
like 10 things at once you know
drive-through lines backed up
in the restaurants backed up they're
just trying to pump out orders
and i'm like dude give these guys a
[ __ ] break you know what i mean it's
crazy
um and then basically the manager kind
of calmed them down and they still
weren't happy
but i mean [ __ ] what it is how did he
calm him down he gave him some chicken
no he's just like look you know we
apologize
we really can't do anything about the
demand right now you know it's crazy
clearly you can
see and then he was just trying to talk
some sense into them and then it
basically took a little while
so i'm [ __ ] sitting there getting
frustrated as [ __ ] so i'm like dude
hurry the [ __ ] up so i could order
yeah you're complaining is holding
everybody back right now and they were
only funneling the line through one
register
so that [ __ ] takes like a good 10 15
minutes or whatever
it dies down the dude in front of me is
and we finally get to
almost my turn the dude in front of me
goes and then he orders a chicken
sandwich right
and then they tell him the same thing oh
you know it's going to be at least like
a 45-minute wait
and he's like cool that's fine i get to
the line
and then i get to the register
and then i look in the back and i just
see piles and piles of chicken
sandwiches
i'm like what what's the 45 minute what
you guys got like a hundred chicken
sandwiches there right
i mean i didn't say that to him i'm just
thinking that right so i'm like um
is it really going to take 45 minutes
because like you guys got a bunch in
there they're like oh
that's all for drive-through though i'm
like you got that many drive-thru orders
and then she's like yeah i mean it's
it's crazy right now so i was like okay
so if i order chicken sandwich then it's
gonna take 45 minutes
and she's like yeah at least most likely
hour and a half
that's [ __ ] i'm crazy all right i
already waited in line for like solid 25
30 minutes i'm gonna eat something so i
just got like tenders or whatever
i wonder if they could could have just
done the sandwich but
[ __ ] the chicken just give me tenders
and put the tenders aside i know right
it might be the same thing
or any substitution um and then so it
took about like 10 minutes for my order
to come out
but then the dude who was in front of me
he he ordered at the same time and his
order got called up
and then i'm like hold up hey man didn't
you order a chicken sandwich
he's like yeah i thought it should only
take like 10 minutes he's like
yeah why the [ __ ] this [ __ ]
let me talk to you man
right now no i didn't say that but i was
pretty busy because i could have gotten
that sandwich for
you know in 10 minutes but i think they
were just saying that basically to kind
of
get people out of there
yeah um but then yeah so i i didn't get
the chicken sandwich that time and then
uh i ended up trying it like a month
after that
and i was like i mean [ __ ] man it's
[ __ ] good but like this
is crazy yeah you think it's better than
um what's it called the gay hating
company what was it chick-fil-a yeah
there it is
chick-fil-a spicy chicken sandwiches
that's just legit man i love that [ __ ]
so if you had if somebody gave you an
option of of a chick-fil-a spicy chicken
sandwich right
chick-fil-a spicy chicken sandwich right
and a fresh
popeye's chicken sandwich but you can't
have sausage with the [ __ ] uh
chick-fil-a sandwich which one because i
that's the thing
i like the chick-fil-a sandwich if i
have the sauce i need the polynesian
sauce with this right so i need i need
the chick-fil-a sauce and the polynesian
sauce yeah
but i'm talking about just the sandwich
okay just a sandwich then popeyes
because they got they got that special
sauce in there yeah yeah yeah but
i do love that [ __ ] chick-fil-a uh
spicy chicken
it's good yeah but they got vegetables
and they got tomatoes and [ __ ]
pepper jack cheese you know you got to
get the deluxe one yeah and then that
polynesians
that sweet to balance out that that uh
spiciness
i can't believe somebody would ever ask
for the manager for at a fast food
restaurant
that's like eating fast food going to
the back and say let me talk to the chef
compliments to the chef you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] lard
they were like really upset they were
they were going off on the girl and and
you could tell like the girl was biting
her tongue too
because obviously they're [ __ ]
stressed out that's probably the
thirteenth person that yelled at her
if if if maybe even more you know
maybe even more but yeah people were
getting to fist there was a
i think there was a popeyes like in
south central or some [ __ ] like that or
whatever it was towards the ocean area
of l.a
but somebody ran somebody over with
their car or like crushed their legs
there was some crazy [ __ ] going on fist
fights
i think people got stabbed over a
[ __ ] chicken sandwich dude
i mean man it brings out the worst in
people man you [ __ ]
uh you know pack people in like that you
make them way best marketing i've ever
heard of in my life i don't even know
how it happened i think somebody else i
don't [ __ ] either all of a sudden
it's just like
everybody on on social media was talking
about this chicken sandwich
and i'm like i don't even know popeyes
was releasing a chicken sandwich
and let alone it's already out and
people are going crazy for it
um and i'm like is it really that i mean
i love popeyes popeyes
make some good [ __ ] chicken um and i
told you the chicken rice [ __ ]
me and dave were talking about this
chicken rice recipe uh the japanese
chicken rice yeah i made it with pot pie
chicken reason that's just [ __ ]
delicious
but anyway i love pot pies more do you
like cherished chicken yeah church
i mean the the honey biscuits bro
chicken is my favorite like i love
popeyes i love all that stuff but still
church chicken his hands are my favorite
church chicken is mom it's also beyonce
loves it too so
i just wish churches also had a spicy
version you know
that's that's what gets me with pot pies
because i always get the spicy no matter
what it is tenders just
you know leg and thigh whatever it's i
always get the spicy because i love that
little extra kick in there
that's my [ __ ] what a little spicy [ __ ]
oh yeah i always like a little spicy man
for sure
you know i just found out too recently
like i didn't know but uh what's called
logic just dropped an album
oh really and he also retired wait so he
dropped an album and retired
in the same bracelet yeah so he retired
and he's actually going to be on twitch
so as a gamer because how old is logic
logic is super young
yeah i think he's like probably now
maybe 28
if i'm not super young right yeah but he
retired retired
wow completely i mean the thing is i
think
he made more money than people usually
do because he's independent
you know so he's playing is he a
completely independent artist
yeah i think he was independent um and
then he was just getting distribution
through a major
oh yeah [ __ ] yeah um so
that's probably why he stacked chips up
pretty quickly because
it's not like he had a huge following
but he had a very loyal following
yeah and then so they would support
everything this dude does and like
he's you know admittedly al always
talking about like uh
being a nerd and like being into like
comics and like video games and all that
so it makes sense
i mean if you know when i when i saw his
uh concert number one yeah
uh i'm not gonna say i'm an avid
listener of logic
i've heard a couple of his tracks and i
think he's dope you know i'm not
for some reason something about his
music didn't allow me to
uh really be drawn into it i don't know
what it is per se
but i will say this i think he's a dope
ass [ __ ] rapper and i love his music
but i don't know why but i don't i can't
recite a single lyric to a logic song
but i [ __ ] with him as a rapper and then
i remember uh
it was a podcast that joe button did and
joe budden was talking about
um i'm not saying i agree with these
sentiments if there's a
you know huge logic fans out there but
he was saying that it feels like
when he raps there's no substance to it
like it's almost soulless
and i don't know if that's the case for
me but for some reason like i appreciate
him as a rapper
but i don't really know any of his songs
i don't know why that is
yeah i mean because the thing is
whenever you have a rapper who tends to
rap a little bit faster
and then they put more words into a bar
it can kind of get lost on you because
it's more stylistic it's like it might
be more fun to listen to
but if you actually do listen to his
music he does have substance in there
um it's just yeah his style tends to be
he's a little bit faster
and then so like even when you listen to
him freestyle i mean he could do it off
the top of the dome
it's like real freestyle but a lot of it
will just kind of be filler words
he's not really saying too much you know
um
so stylistically i mean it might not be
everybody's cup of tea but at the end of
the day i feel like
he's he carved his own path and i
respect that and i admire that you know
um i don't know if it's kind of
interesting because when he
he said he's going into twitch right and
twitch is a huge platform
yeah but it's but i saw a video of him
kind of explaining why he's going to
leave and i guess like one of the
reasons why he said he was gonna leave
was because he wants to be a family
because he has a kid now or a daughter
which i thought was a little odd i'm
like you can't be a parent
and make music but i guess he's just
done done kind of creating music for
other people
because i think as an artist he's still
going to create music he's still going
to rap over stuff probably still release
mixtapes or whatever
but i don't think he has like a goal in
pursuit of creating another album and
kind of making
rap his career i mean financially he's
completely stable he was
grammy-nominated twice
in his early twenties yeah you know now
and now that i know as an independent
artist
i think he won like a bt what he did
he's done a lot of [ __ ] i don't even
know he was black
yeah i think he's a half black half
white that [ __ ] looked all
white yeah i would have never known yeah
and uh the thing is he comes from uh you
know pretty rough uh
background like his i think both his
parents were drug addicts
you know yeah his dad was like in and
out of jail i guess and so
he he kind of grew up in a in a rough
environment in a rough area
and uh he has i think one or two older
brothers
and they were kind of into that street
life as well um
so he might seem like you're kind of
cookie cutter white kid almost
but it's just uh i don't know that's
just kind of like
the identity he carved out for himself
or even like
the the persona as an artist yeah um and
that's what i'm saying
i respect this like he's not really
trying to flex too much about
oh yeah you know i'm hood and i'm pretty
sure like
in his beginning days he he definitely
had
um a little bit of inner turmoil with
that like trying to decide
you know am i going to try to be the
street rapper type of thing or am i
going to be
a little bit more because i would i
would categorize him as like more of a
conscious rapper
yeah yeah that's kind of what he's on um
a backpack rapper i mean
yeah yeah yeah um and it worked for him
dude i mean
he he just stayed genuine um didn't
really try to cater
to uh like a certain audience by being a
certain way
he just did him and then it appealed to
a wide group of people
and that's why he his fan base were so
loyal
he has a very interesting fan base too
because i
i watch this logic documentary on
netflix and when you look at the crowd
it's all white kids i see a single
[ __ ] black person out there
i'm like yo what the [ __ ] that's so
interesting yeah he definitely
targeted a very specific demographic
especially for his popularity but i mean
that's the thing it's that
like when you're starting out as an
artist
you might have a certain idea of who
you're targeting
in terms of your audience but then you
just discover that through the music you
put out right
and you have to have a certain level of
business savvy
in order to basically capitalize on that
i'm not saying that
you know he's only thinking or not just
him but but any artists who've who've
done well independently
uh are thinking it only from a business
perspective but you have to think about
the business perspective too because at
the end of the day you're trying to do
this [ __ ] for a living
yeah and like so many artists are
giving out free music just to start
building that fan base
but at the end of the day it's like okay
well if you're not making money through
music and you're spending this much time
and energy through it then
how are you surviving what are you doing
um
and that's either when they're working
another job or they're really hitting
the the performance side hard they're
just doing small shows
i'm just glad it's it's kind of nice the
fact that he has a young fan base just
because
i think we're finding out recently just
because of how uh
digestible music is and how quick it is
and how quick it's delivered to
everybody else
how how much it transforms people just
get
stuck on this quick little hype super
fast
yeah and then out of nowhere they'll be
done with it like for example remember
that kid
uh that korean kid that uh he bit off
that one song from that dude
og mako uh oh yeah uh keith ape keith
yeah right
and when he when that kid hopped on that
[ __ ] wave
of just screaming into a mic i don't
know what the [ __ ] that is i actually
listened to it the other day again
and i was like damn i still don't like
the song but
when he's popped off doing that [ __ ]
everybody was rapping like him
even people who weren't rapping like him
originally and they started rapping like
him
and that lasted what two years and then
you don't hear that [ __ ] anymore at all
yeah it was such a weird moment and yeah
i got a lot of heat for this [ __ ] too
because i remember i i didn't like that
song because
i remember listening to it and i was
like damn this just sounds so familiar
it sounds like
something i heard before and it was that
dude og mako song
and then i kind of was a little
irritated by that
right just because this kid the music
video stylistically
stole everything from the original music
video yeah it wasn't a rendition of it
that his the flow all the the ad-libs
everything was just like that dude
og-mako stuff and
i didn't hear when it dropped it didn't
say inspired by or anything
yeah there was no credit given to that
yeah there was only credit given to og
mako until
after he kind of was a little upset
about it and then i think
the the public was kind of like well why
can't he just make dope music is still a
dope song it's like well that's not the
point
somebody else already put his spin and
his taste and there's always his hard
work into it
and you stole everything you didn't give
the dude credit
and then you blew up your career off of
somebody else's hard work and i don't
give a [ __ ] if he's korean or not
you know that that's that's my people
but you have to give credit where credit
is due and when i saw that and i'm like
and people are looking at him as he's as
if he's an originator it's like no he
stole that [ __ ]
that dude keith keith what keith gabe
keith
yeah keith ape yeah keith ape whatever
keith monkey whatever the [ __ ] his name
is
this [ __ ] stole that [ __ ] you
know i'm not saying that you know people
can't like his music but
you know facts are facts it wasn't
inspired by it wasn't a derivative it
was
stolen almost it was beat for b ad lib
for ad-lib
you know yeah the music video was very
similar yeah yeah no i remember
when uh i saw that too and i was just
kind of like
not not surprised really because um
the korean music industry has had a
history of doing that
let's say borrowing from western culture
and western music
um and then it wasn't until like the
whole k-pop
scene and like k-hip-hop scene kind of
became a movement in a powerhouse that
they started
doing things that were more original
because they started to attract
foreign producers and foreign
songwriters you know people in europe
people here in america top songwriters
and top producers
and then so they were doing like
original [ __ ] for them but prior to that
prior to k-pop and k-hip-hop getting
there
there was a lot of a lot of borrowing
from from western music
you know um and it's like
they say imitation is the highest form
of flattery right
but you know there there has to be kind
of a line with that of like
if you're not acknowledging that yeah
you were inspired by this artist or
inspired by
that song or that album whatever the
case may be and there's
clear correlations between the two
especially when you when your career
blew up on it
i think that was the thing that that
bothered me it was
you know because i remember people
hearing that's like yo this korean dude
is blowing up you should be super happy
that a korean dude is killing it in the
american rap scene
and i'm like in my mind i'm like doing
what though he stole that [ __ ]
you know gave no credit where credit was
due and once again people might be like
he did after it doesn't matter if you
did it after his career already blew up
off of it
you know and i think that dude og mako's
video did well
because they they had to go back and
backtrack to a song which it already had
millions of views but they did more
views after
keith apes song blew up yeah but it was
something about that just didn't sit
right because i would hate as an artist
to
add my own unique personal spin mm-hmm
um
and then you see somebody else do it and
they're giving that person all the
credit that would for sure
that would kill me on the other side for
sure i mean like how would you not feel
salty about that
you know it's like what the [ __ ] man you
just straight up jack my [ __ ]
and there's a problem too with some
sometimes with i feel like in in in a
younger generation where they go
well what does it matter like you know
people like it anyways like that's not
the [ __ ] point
you are profiting off of somebody else's
hard work and
now there's this conversation that
people just don't give a [ __ ] they go
well who cares
they're they're creating something i'm
like what are they that's
this is a weird line i don't understand
where it became okay to
completely steal something from somebody
else just because
you wanted to and as long as people are
just having fun
well people aren't just having fun some
people get hurt by this their careers
get hurt by this you know
yeah no for sure i mean i think
it's um a little bit tricky with that
when it delves into kind of the creative
realm
because it's not something that's
tangible you know it's not like
you can see the thoughts and the ideas
of somebody uh
an artist and and it's out there for you
to physically look at and hold and touch
and see
it that translates into a body of work
right it it translates into like a music
or
you know whatever form of art that they
might be creating
and then when somebody takes that and
like kind of copies it
i feel like there's a little bit of a
disconnect there um
it's not like making knockoff of shoes
right
you have a tangible product and you make
a knockoff of it and then people are in
up in arms like what the [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] you know look at this
look at this [ __ ] knock off right
because it's it's it's a in
you're talking about this um in a
creative space there might be a little
bit of a disconnect there
and that's also tied to things like
where people always try to
kind of lowball creators graphic
designers
website designers because it's like well
you could do it for free right
i mean we'll give you the exposure you
know um
we'll give you a shout out or you know
we'll give you more projects down the
line
but then it's like it's because you
don't understand
the type of work like can you do this
yeah can you do this in the amount of
time that you're wanting me to do this
well i also think people are okay with
their artists that they look up to
stealing other people's stuff
because they want to be okay with
stealing somebody else's [ __ ] i really
do believe it because
they want to be like well if he did it
that's okay because you want to be okay
because you don't have the talent
you don't have the hard work or the
ethic and you're this person who has
no [ __ ] artistic bone in your body
and you want to be okay
popping off and stealing somebody else's
[ __ ] so you want to support an artist
who does that too well i mean [ __ ] man
that that is true in some cases where
people
who don't really have that raw natural
talent they don't
and they want to do it the only way they
can do it
is to continually borrow yeah and we all
we all are kind of a conglomeration of
all the people that we look up to
sure for sure you know my comedy things
that i say
and sometimes even on this podcast like
i'll say a joke me thinking that
everybody knows where it comes from and
they go
yo david that's really funny and i'm
like yo that's not my joke like that's a
joke from i don't know like
a tv show yeah that was a joke from this
other comedian yeah i'm assuming
that they know but i would never take
credit for it yeah somebody asked me
like yo is that your joke i don't mean
like yeah man i'm funny and i'd be like
no that's actually a reference from i
don't know
uh what's it called parks and rec or
that's a that's a joke from the office
that reminds me of uh with jay uh jay-z
because like there was a point when
people like oh you always
biting off biggie's lines right but his
thing is like
no i'm i'm bigging up biggie you know by
saying those
and i think that was kind of the same
thing for him it's just like biggie is
such an iconic rapper
that even if i say those lines you know
where it's from yeah i don't think
[ __ ] yeah but then i think on the black
album i forget which song it was but
he did clarify that he did have a line
about that he's like
uh when i say a big verse i'm only
bigging up my brother
or something like that yeah yeah so he
was kind of addressing that but
same thing of what you're talking about
is that because it's so
iconic or it's so like legendary you
assume people might know
you know uh but they might not
and then think it's either original or
you're jacking somebody
yeah you know it's like if i if i make a
uh
like when i was doing these vlogs back
in the day right i did a lot of like
dave chappelle jokes right but it was
knowing the audience knew it was a dave
and we're laughing about it being a dave
chappelle joke right we're not laughing
at is as if it's my original joke yeah
it's a joke that i'm referencing that
everybody is in on they go oh that [ __ ]
is funny that's dave chappelle joke
you know there's a difference you know
and i i think when i was younger too
like i s there was a certain point too i
stopped listening to other stand-up
comics because i was so scared that
it would bleed into my comedy yeah and
yeah i know exactly
and i was scared that i would be
somebody that was jacking somebody
else's [ __ ] without even knowing it
and uh it did happen a couple of times i
forgot what what what joke it was but
somebody came up to me after
uh a comedy club like you stole that
joke i was like which joke
and they referenced the joke and then i
looked it up later i was like oh [ __ ]
did i hear this joke before
yeah you know did i steal this joke and
i didn't know but that guy was visibly
upset
and by the way when uh the person that
he said i took the joke from
uh [ __ ] i wish i could remember but you
know it was like a personal friend of
his or whatever
and i i had to take a step back and like
did i hear this from somewhere else
because it was almost spot on to the
joke that i made
um but then it's it kind of went in my
line of like parallel thinking because
there was enough distinction was like no
i don't know who this comic is it wasn't
because you know that comic was asian
i'm asian so there's
definitely parallel thinking in that
kind of case yeah but um
i can understand where that dude came
from if i stole his buddy's joke
um and there was another time too where
i made a joke and i think it was a joke
that i heard on mad tv and it was in my
stand up and i didn't realize it until
later on when i was on youtube and i was
just watching a bunch of random [ __ ] and
i was like oh [ __ ] i got that joke from
that sketch
and then i took it out of my bit because
somebody wrote that joke yeah but and
that's why i started getting scared
where i stopped watching stand-up comics
no
i mean but you know the it's that's the
thing is that when you're a student of
your craft
and you're consuming um all of these all
this material
all the greats and you're kind of
building like a strong base and
foundation to understand and build on
top
like build your craft on top of that
it's hard not to get influenced
you know and and i did a similar thing
when i was working on my life imitates
art ep
through the entirety of it i just
quarantined myself like from from music
that was out there because i'm like
dude if i hear something that's popping
or i hear something that i really enjoy
i might want to do something like that
you know um
and i didn't want to do that i wanted to
kind of explore
um the subject matter that i was
tackling
and then make make a like a whole body
of work based around that
without it really being influenced
because i didn't want it to be like
oh but do i have a song in here that
could be like a hit
single you know do i have a song in here
that could be like a club jam
that that wasn't what was driving that
project it was just like
do i like what i'm putting out here
um and do i like it as a complete song
you know from the production to the
writing
to like the the rhyme scheme to the flow
my cadence everything and just looking
at it like
point by point and then making sure it
creates a whole body of work
right that that is true to me and that i
enjoy yeah it's weird because there's a
fine line too because
um i had a conversation with this dude
his name is russell he's also a rapper
and i think there's a huge fallacy that
some of some people
maybe maybe in an older generation but
maybe just artists in general sometimes
like we forget to also consume art
and so because we're scared that we're
going to either steal stuff
or sometimes it just comes from a very
hateful place so what i always say too
like like [ __ ] this guy i don't want to
listen to this [ __ ] but at the same time
it's like it's it's like with food right
how do you know what good food is if you
haven't tasted grapefruit absolutely
and you you could sit here and judge
somebody else's dishes
judge what somebody else is making at a
different restaurant who's doing really
really well
and say that that [ __ ] is trash but how
would you know unless you tasted it for
sure
you wouldn't know for sure so i i always
try to
try to find that good balance of you
know making sure that i'm not
taking too much but also appreciating
because i have to remember i have to be
a consumer first i have to appreciate
art first before i even try to create it
no for sure
for sure and that's that's the student
aspect of it yeah
you need to study that [ __ ] whatever
your craft is you got to study that [ __ ]
all the greats who came before you right
they're they're great and they're
legendary for a reason
so that part i completely agree with you
you have to understand what is great
what makes it great and why it's
timeless
from there though is and what i meant by
like when i quarantine myself from from
like the music i mean
i mean like new music [ __ ] that was
popping
right then at that moment i didn't want
to be influenced by what's
trendy right now you know what i mean
yeah i want to
take what kind of it's it's like
encompasses your whole journey as an
artist almost
right because up to that point
everything that you've done everything
that you've consumed everything that you
learned everything you practiced on or
whatever
it comes out in that one project and
then the same in the next project and
the same in the next part
and then so like i just wanted to make
sure that it was true to me
and as pure as i could be as
unadulterated as possible
uh as pos as possible as it can be you
know
yeah do you do you miss performing music
dude all the time man really i [ __ ]
hate performing actually
i [ __ ] hate performing like even like
stand up yeah i i get the uh
i get that itch every now and then right
and then i'll go to a club or whatever
i'll go to a college and then i'll set
up a stand like small little college
store to do stand-up yeah but then once
that it's just scratched i'm like eh
whatever i mean it's i don't know man
it's it's unexplainable kind of like
that
stage high you know of like i just want
to be a hype man dude
i just want to know i want that one
[ __ ] white towel on my shoulder
and i just want to [ __ ] say some [ __ ]
[Music]
i want you to say a word and then i'm
gonna say a word right after yeah
[ __ ] hey
popeye's chicken that's all i want to do
with the one white [ __ ] towel that's
it yeah i mean
but it's it kind of goes in tandem
though it's like it's not just a
performance thing but also creating
content too
right you got to have something to
perform
and so i deeply miss both aspects of
that
um and yeah man like even with the music
thing
um you know i've told you this before
but
you know when i dropped the life
imitates art ep the plan
was to release three more um eps within
a year
that was kind of the timeline and then
so like even after i had wrapped up
um life imitates art like uh jeff and i
uh we were already starting to work on
kind of what's next
but what had happened was my creative
tank just was on empty dude yeah i i
mean
i didn't realize it i just thought i hit
like a creative wall
which happens right yeah but my process
through that has always been
i'm just gonna force my way out of this
just keep bulldozing
through that wall and then at some point
you're gonna pick back up you're gonna
find that rhythm again
but two just like months and months and
months of
unfinished songs you know one verse two
verse
uh a hook no verse right half a hook
and i'm like dude i can't [ __ ] finish
anything and and
none of it is when i look back at it i'm
like okay this can become something
i'm just like ah i think i want to
rewrite that were you listening to a lot
of music at the time
i think i was consuming more at that
point once once i
realized i wasn't getting out of this
rut just to feel more inspired
and and here's the thing too man is that
even though
hip-hop is my favorite genre that's the
genre that i listen to least when i'm
listening to music leisurely yeah i
listen to all different other or all
different
um types of genres of music and so
you know i i would like listen to music
that i
i would like to um or
not like that i would think that i might
be inspired by
um and then searching for kind of like
obscure [ __ ] to maybe i could draw
something from here draw something from
there but
not dude it just it just became really
stagnated
and then it got to the point where i'm
like all right i need to just take a
break from it
you know and that was the first break i
ever took from music since i think i was
like 16.
art is just a weird career to go into
there is nothing that really
dictates there's no consistency yeah
there is
there's no blueprint there's no path
there's some people who are just really
good at just
constantly creating and there's just a
that's a small
few right but there's other people who
just you know who kind of flow into this
art realm but they're more business
people you know i've seen people who are
more successful
in in the art realm but if but you look
at their art it's very whatever it's
very mundane but they're very consistent
at what they do yeah you know and so
they can kind of balance both pieces
right like i'll use a great example is
like somebody like kevin hart
you know kevin hart he's a hard-ass
[ __ ] worker you know he created this
huge company he's probably the number
one comedian out there
uh does does anybody look at kevin hart
and say he is the funniest
man alive probably not right but i don't
know if that's ever his goal
uh if that's what he wants to do but
he's somebody that i think is is a good
balance of his funny and his art and his
business
you know yeah cause nobody's ever gonna
look at kevin hart and say yo he was the
closest thing to chappelle
he was the closest thing to louis c.k he
was the closest thing to
bill burr um richard pryor eddie murphy
i don't know if he's within that
conversation when it comes to comedy
right but that's not a knock on him
though that's just people who were here
you know but at the same time those
people never built empires like kevin
hart did yeah you know so he he
he has that really he could pump out
content constantly so when i
when i first met kevin hart first of all
really nice guy like a
super nice dude makes eye contact when
he talks to you just a really busy guy
but just watching him work and seeing
how busy he is he's always on his phone
texting somebody doing something else
even before he was about to hit the
stage so i did this small sketch with
him where
it was for his lol network yeah and we
did this
um it was this [ __ ] stupid sketch
it's basically where he had to critique
a bunch of my nude photos
and so yeah you know it was [ __ ]
funny to do this cracking up the whole
time but he shot this right before he
was about to do a stand-up show
huge [ __ ] stand-up show yeah like at
the at the pasadena whatever
and we're sitting there and i'm like
he's about to go up on stage in about 10
minutes yeah or like 15 minutes and he
shot the sketch with me in like eight or
seven
yeah and then he goes up on stage and
kills it it's like damn i
i think if i was going to do a show i
don't think i want to [ __ ] see
anybody get the [ __ ] out of here
but he's shooting all these sketches
right before he's about to go
compartmentalize
yeah i don't know how he [ __ ] does
that that's amazing yeah because i don't
have that in me i'm more like
i'm not feeling good i gotta get in the
zone guys i got to stop but i gotta
pop my chicken sandwich and see what
happens you know but it's it's weird
because
people do ask how do you balance this
out and it's hard to say because
when i was when i first started off in
specifically the youtube space
i had to force creativity all the time
specifically because i was always scared
that
um if i don't create something i'm going
to disappear
which that fear is still there and that
truth is still there specifically in the
way content is consumed
now for sure if you're not always doing
something you're not on somebody's
platform you're not working and people
don't see your face they forget about
you that very [ __ ] next day
and the only drive that i have now is to
make sure that not so much that people
will remember me is that i
hate seeing other asian comics that are
[ __ ] trash
that are doing well i hate i [ __ ]
hate it i absolutely [ __ ] hate it man
and they're recycling all these old
jokes that i've made like
i just literally go online and i see
these jokes it's like that was literally
word for word a joke that i made
the [ __ ] video goes viral and i'm
like that's not the [ __ ] or i'll see
something that bart and joe did yeah and
then these other
you know obviously these asian kids grew
up watching me bart and joe their whole
lives and they're recycling our jokes
but they're putting it in tik tok form
or some [ __ ] and i'm like the [ __ ] is
this
different platform different platform
like [ __ ] these kids dude
but i understand that like for them i
get it because it's like if we were
influencing their life
it's going to happen just at least
change it up a little bit you know take
take the influence don't take the
[ __ ] jokes
yeah but so like for you then if there's
that worry
of you know con like that creativity
well
running dry right what would you
kind of shift into then let's say
hypothetically prostitution dude
i suck some dick dude i'm [ __ ] good
at that [ __ ] because i'm sure because
i'm sure you've had
had those moments where you think about
that you know it's like if if this
this path doesn't continue to um
be a clear path for me like what do i
transition into
from there [ __ ] i don't even know i
don't i've never really thought about
that like i've uh
i mean obviously i opened up a bunch of
businesses so you know that's always
gonna be the fail safe right
um and the only reason why i thought
about doing that was because
i like food yeah but even that was
driven by by an artistry thing
you know i don't know the business side
that's why i have business partners that
they own way more than i do because i'm
just there for
the the branding side um dealing with
the food part and that's really about it
that's what i'm good at
yeah but i don't know to be you know
there was a time too when somebody even
asked me what would happen if
you know when you were doing youtube and
youtube the next day was shut down what
would you be doing
i don't [ __ ] know it wouldn't be my
whole world though because i've seen
these funny ass clips
it's like these like 14 year olds or 15
year olds their
account got banned and they do a whole
youtube video bawling their eyes out
like i don't know what
i'm gonna do with my life little [ __ ]
shut the [ __ ] up
well that's the weird like i i always
want people to understand this too
if you are make your career is not your
life it's
not it's always going to be you have any
idea how many times
people have changed their careers and
their lifespan yeah if your whole life
is based on your work
you're going to be [ __ ] when work is
over especially when it comes to a time
when you have to retire
or not even have to when you choose to
retire yeah well you're not that cool
thing when you're not that pretty little
thing out there well you're not the
funniest person out there
that's a scary scary thought for people
because they don't even see that
they make their career their whole life
and that's all they see
they make public perception their whole
life they make popularity
uh a factor in how happy they are and
when all that stuff is taken away they
don't know what to do
when i see these videos of some some
younger people and not even younger
people i'm talking kids in their 20s
they i don't know they get banned from a
certain platform because they did a
little too much
you know trying to get views and they
start breaking down in crime they go
what am i going to do
what's you know what's what's life it's
like [ __ ]
move on it's because you know
there there we're in a kind of a time
and culture where these kids place value
in things that are so superficial
and that are so temporary you know look
at twitter for example
twitter is the worst example of it all
sometimes
i go on twitter and i follow specific
people because i want to see
what kind of [ __ ] somebody's going
to complain about today
right and there's this there there is
this toxic relationship
that a lot of people have on twitter and
social media platforms it's like
what kind of extra woke stupid [ __ ] am i
going to talk about today
just so i get an extra heart yeah right
they're like let's normalize this
let's do they say these things not
because they believe it they say it
because they know that the general crowd
is gonna back them and the more hearts
that they get on this [ __ ] tweet
is gonna make them feel like they're an
important person yeah and that's why
a lot of this activism online is a bunch
of [ __ ] because none of you are out
there actually doing stuff
unless there was a camera if unless
there was a post to say that you're
a [ __ ] great human being and has and
it has to do with virtue signaling
and so that's why even now like for
example let's just talk about this right
there's this dude name
recently that happened his name is jacob
blake right he was shot seven times in
the back yeah
and there was a bunch of things that
came out they go oh he was a i don't
know i i mean i read somewhere that they
were saying that he had a
he had priors or whatever which is
always besides the point people love to
bring that [ __ ] up right
he was breaking up a fight with these
two women
cops got involved and they were tussling
around and so with the blurry footage
cell phone footage
they said that he was wrestling the cops
to me i i don't know
it looked like he was breaking up that
fight and then the cops got involved and
they were all just kind of wrestling
together and he got up
went outside and supposedly he went to
go he opened up the door and the cops
were quote unquote trying to stop him
which they weren't they just stopped him
with bullets exactly so they just drew
guns and he was walking back to his door
to his car very slowly it wasn't like he
was running towards it yeah like he was
gonna grab for something
and they had ample enough time to stop
him tackle him take him down
arrest him or something but instead what
they did was he walked to his door they
grabbed at his tank top and they shot
him in the back seven times
yeah and now he's alive but he's
paralyzed so
you know with this type of stuff this is
arguably just as terrible as george
floyd's situation right
and when the blm movement started
happening because of the george floyd
situation
and what i'm trying to say is that with
this situation with this guy jacob blake
you'd even hear about it like
the social currency is gone yeah people
aren't getting their social currency
from it
yeah and so they don't want to say
anything or either that or they're
exhausted
i understand you know we all get
emotionally exhausted when we continue
to do these things because it's very
difficult
but where's that same [ __ ] energy is
it because you don't see the million
tweets is it because you don't see all
of that stuff that you don't want to
talk about this anymore
and and that's the sad part i don't want
to hear [ __ ] from somebody who
like for example uh i i gotta i remember
well i [ __ ] roasted this girl on
instagram yeah because
she uh she was like well where are you
at when it comes to all these
asian american uh issues and i [ __ ]
roasted this
i was like first of all young [ __ ]
you don't know me like that yeah number
two i am the last person you could ever
say that to you must not know who the
[ __ ] i am
and that's the funny thing too it's like
for her she wanted
the virtue signaling thing of me calling
out a social media quote unquote star
and i put him on blast that's what she
wanted from that conversation yeah which
was so stupid because if she did a
little bit of research
she would know who the [ __ ] i am it's
like you know what i mean
i'm like i don't think you understand in
my case and i'm not just tooting my own
[ __ ] horn
i there's a lot of people who came
before a lot of these younger kids
that were asian americans that stood up
for [ __ ] before we even got praised for
it
we didn't get praise for this [ __ ] i had
to get a bunch of these comments oh why
are you trying to act black
why do you do all this other stuff you
don't get those comments kids because i
was the one taking those bullets for you
so you don't get to say that [ __ ] to me
but the reason why she did that and she
didn't care to look at who i was
is because she wanted to be praised for
calling somebody out
she didn't do that because she actually
cared about the asian american community
she did that [ __ ] because she wanted a
pet on the [ __ ] back and i hate it i
[ __ ] hate that [ __ ] yeah
i mean it's a
tricky thing man i mean like you said
would you the point you alluded to about
people do anything for likes you know
it's sad
it is sad it's it's it's [ __ ]
terrible and and it's
uh no wonder why so many people get
depressed
yeah it's it's like you put your value
in that you put your self-worth in that
and you don't get what you're hoping for
or expecting
and then as a result you just feel
obliterated and empty
it's like why why are you seeking
value and worth in in just this
it's fleeting yeah it is it is it's
so temporary and so quick right
it's like a high you know what i mean
it's it's like a [ __ ] line of yay man
you might be on cloud nine for about 10
minutes 15 minutes
but once that high dies down you're
gonna need more
and i'm gonna start calling some of
these other people on their [ __ ] too
because
there's you know certain people who were
on this space before where they were
they were very preachy about doing stuff
for the art and the next thing you know
they're complaining that they're not
getting enough views it's like okay
those two things are very [ __ ] simple
you know if you were just only doing
this for the art
and by the way i'm not like that either
i yeah i do it for
you know i wanted i only put up stuff if
i personally find it funny
or if it's a topic that i want to talk
about but
there's a reason why it gets views i
understand these type of things
but i only do it to a certain extent i'm
not sitting here denying that when i was
when i first started out youtube i
wasn't trying to find out what was going
to pop off
yeah like these topics that i were
talking that i was talking about
i was thinking avidly thinking like okay
what is going to be really funny what
what do people want to hear i i was in
that position before
but some sometimes too it's like they're
they were the ones
that were criticizing the youth about
only doing things for likes
when they're in that same group too they
just don't want to admit it right
you know and it's it's dumb like you
can't criticize these young kids for
stuff that you're still doing now yeah
you know they didn't they chose not to
evolve in this space their [ __ ] don't
smell
you know what i mean that's the
mentality it's sad yeah
you you can't you can't base your whole
career off of what other people think
it it goes absolutely nowhere it's the
same thought that i have about money now
when up there was a certain point when i
was on youtube and
all i thought about was putting as much
videos as i can working as much just so
i could stack all these chips and
make a [ __ ] ton of [ __ ] money what
did that do for me did absolutely
nothing
i found out that number one i didn't
care about an absorbent amount of money
number two i understand listen i'm not
saying i don't want
money yeah
yeah i mean i like being comfortable i
like not worrying about my next paycheck
yeah i'm talking about the means beyond
that right fancy cars
uh the nicest shoes out there the nicest
clothes out there
flexing you know flexing on grandma
about the [ __ ] that i have that's the
type of stuff i could literally care
less about
yeah and sometimes when i have
conversations with friends who um who
have
a [ __ ] ton of money they're like
gajillionaires and you know they they
work really hard and they're trying to
talk to me about material things and i'm
sitting there just with just
dozing off because i don't [ __ ] care
it's like yo man i just got this [ __ ]
mclaren i got this and that yeah it's
like it's [ __ ] sick right and i look
at them i'm like
i don't [ __ ] care i'm not hating on
your car
you're talking about [ __ ] that i have i
find absolutely no [ __ ] value in yeah
you know because there was a certain
point when i made a lot of money i
bought a lot of dumb [ __ ]
and it didn't fill anything for me i was
like yo i just wasted a lot of money
but we had that conversation too it's
because you know
your starting point though you know if
you're coming from a financial
background
where you didn't have everything or you
didn't have a lot of things even
of what you wanted and then you got a
little taste of money
and and kind of like that freedom to
purchase these things that you weren't
able to purchase before
i feel like everybody goes through that
you know yeah
and you're like it's not because you're
necessarily trying to flex
it's more like i'm gonna have everything
that i want yeah like i work this hard
this is something that i want and that i
can realistically afford
i'm gonna do this as a reward to myself
or reward for myself
but then like you said after you've kind
of scratched that
itch it's just like yeah i mean yeah it
was nice buying something for myself
it was nice having those nice things but
it didn't change my life in any
way somebody would told me jordan ones
were the most uncomfortable shoe ever
and then [ __ ] are the nicest
looking kicks yeah
uncomfortable but when you got like just
regular sized feet if it's not like a
skinny width
that [ __ ] you wear that an hour and
you're done that's about it
i've seen people with the fattest feet
wear jordan ones and they look like
[ __ ] uh
with skate shoes after because they not
such fat feedings
don't stretches out the leather i'm like
bro did you stuff socks in those
it's like that's just my regular street
fighter feet
[ __ ] puzzle fighter has street
fighter feet and stuff that's
weird man yeah i mean it's you know
materialism
i mean teach their own right some people
get
huge satisfaction from that and and they
feel um
fantastic by buying themselves these
nice things
um i mean people like you and i
are not so much in that camp you're just
kind of like like i told you before man
like for me i get excited about
going grocery shopping filling up my
fridge you know
when i open my fridge and i have a full
fridge that [ __ ] makes me feel
fulfilled yeah like that [ __ ] makes me
feel like like full inside
yeah when i fill up a full tank of gas
same type of feeling
you know yeah and so it's like these are
just basic things where i'm like you
know what
my basic needs are met and i don't have
to worry about that
i don't have to worry about if i got
enough food in my fridge or if i got
enough
you know to eat and drink i don't have
to worry about oh can i
afford a full tank of gas to get to
where i need to get to you know
those basic things man i i know it might
sound like
stupid but that's just how i'm
programmed when i have those things
my basic needs being met like that i
just feel fulfilled
because there were times when things
were a struggle you know
and so i appreciate that i don't take it
for granted and then so
when i am able to buy myself a nice
thing and i don't really
buy things too much but once in a while
i want
something like for example my most
i would say big purchase that i've met
uh that made in like the past year
electric scooter i got it during last
black friday
yeah and it was i got it for like a buck
fifty it was like a big sale
but did i need that no i did it but
i rode the electric scooter enough to to
know that i enjoy it
and and i have fun with it and i'm like
i gotta pay eight ten bucks each time i
write this like the lift scooters or
whatever yeah well you know what i'm
just gonna buy it
and then i'll i'll wear it out in like a
year or two but i get my money's worth
yeah you know having the freedom
and ability to do things like that also
feels good
but if i didn't get that scooter would
it impact my life negatively no
i wouldn't be like oh man i feel so
empty now that i can't have you know
this thing that i want
it's like nah i got a full fridge and a
full tank of gas
clothes on my back roof over my head i'm
good man like perspective is a huge
thing and you know
i think sometimes people believe that
money might change
you right but i don't really believe
that stuff i think if you were a [ __ ]
person to begin with oh yeah that's just
who you are
now you could literally be an [ __ ]
and it doesn't [ __ ] matter yeah you
chose not to be even a bigger [ __ ]
because you were so [ __ ] broke
that you were worried you know about
your paycheck that was coming in so you
kind of kept your mouth shut
but now that you don't have to worry
about that [ __ ] your worst qual the
worst qualities about yourself that
people can't check you on anymore
you're just saying whatever the [ __ ] you
want yeah and i think that's what people
are finding out about um
because ellen you hear about ellen just
having a yeah ellen has been getting a
lot of [ __ ] for sure
she's been taking a lot of heat man and
i don't i personally i didn't even know
what that [ __ ] was about until recently
because i
you know everybody's been getting
cancelled
but then ella's been getting so much
heat consistently
i started to you know i got a little
curious about what's going on but there
was a lot of sexual harassment
allegations from her staff
specifically her producers where they
were
i guess one of them i think it was a
male producer and i think he's i think
he's
uh lgbt and he
he grabbed somebody's dick or something
like that or some [ __ ] yeah
i'm like yo well how the [ __ ] do you get
away with this stuff you just walk up
and just swipe a dick and then all of a
sudden
hey there buddy how secure in your job
do you have to be to come up grab dick
and be like yeah i'm still going to work
tomorrow yeah that's [ __ ] nuts to me
you never played off as a joke i got you
yeah that was like sexual advancements i
guess
there was some intimidation tactics too
they would they would kind of treat
interns very unfairly and kind of make
them feel that they're going to lose
their job the next day
which isn't very great for company
culture or morale for sure
and i think her response was to number
one obviously do a public apology saying
like this isn't what my company
i thought my company was was about um
and so she fired those three people
within her company
and i think a lot of people started to
feel that those are just scapegoats like
yeah
you're kind of appeasing people firing
these human beings when you are
responsible for your company
yeah i mean because it kind of trickles
from the top down right yeah
you can't say that you were completely
oblivious to what was going
on yeah when it's your [ __ ] show
yeah and you're the boss you know yeah
sure you got people under you to take
care of the day-to-day stuff
but to say i had no idea
this type of stuff was going on i think
that's a little bit far-fetched you know
yeah it's hard i mean definitely when
your company grows it's hard to
uh kind of keep up with the day-to-day
stuff right
but when it's the whole company as a
whole as a whole they feel
this way like a majority of the
employees and like how distant are you
from your company
where you're well you can also put out a
statement and say that my goal in this
company was to make sure this was a
positive environment well how the [ __ ]
can you say that when you're not
involved into
in anything exactly it's been going on
for quite a while apparently
yeah well and then she's also been
getting heat like herself
right kind of her behavior and uh what'd
they say about that
uh just that she's not a nice person
that she's done a lot of yeah a lot of
mean things to people
um and and it kind of goes against the
whole
uh tv image and persona that they've
built her as
right this this fun loving generous
you know very approachable type
personality in person
yet she's very um
i guess uh i don't know what the word
for it would be um i don't want to say
evil
you know uh but definitely just just not
a
not a nice person man i mean that's also
the public's fault too because
it's weird when sometimes people see
this persona and they go and they meet
that person
and they say well you're not like how
you are on tv it's like
i mean i say this consistently some of
the most likable people you'll meet out
there are some of the
most worst human beings you'll ever get
to know because likability doesn't mean
that you're a good human being no
and there's a huge distinction and
people don't understand that there's
people who are likable because they're
snakes
they're [ __ ] foxes and they do that
because they want to get
something out of you they know that they
understand that that they're if they're
cordial with you
that they can receive something out of
this relationship
those are likable human beings they
understand social context they
understand how to make you feel good
however that doesn't mean that you're a
good
person right completely different and
that's the case for for ellen you see
this online persona
and then you find out something else
about them it's like well
you don't [ __ ] know her personally
she could be a terrible person why even
be shocked by that exactly
and that's the difference is that a
public persona
doesn't mean it's a private persona you
know
um and like i think a lot of times
people mistaken
what they're seeing as oh that's who
they are as a person
that's who i know this person and then
like you said no a lot of times you
don't know [ __ ]
you know yeah you absolutely don't [ __ ]
i think uh it's funny mariel's best
friend said that uh
she kind of figured how different people
can be on and off camera when she met me
because when she found out that marielle
was going to date me she assumed that i
was gonna be this super loud
obnoxious guy yeah she's like you're
actually very very sweet i was like yeah
of course like this
of course i am [ __ ] what are you saying
no it's not and it's i understand yeah
because
it happens a lot too sometimes with
these fan interactions and
this is very few and far between and
people like these terrible fan meetup
stories but i'll give you one for an
example
there was a there was a kid who um
i don't know if it's because actually i
do know it's because he sees these rant
videos right
and i'm just hyper opinionated about
stuff and it's it's in this three
or three or four minute clip and during
that time on youtube people had a very
short attention span for content
so it was old stamp that i would do and
i would chop it up or whatever
and so i'm sitting there and i remember
meeting this dude up
he was out of college and this guy is
just screaming non-stop just like yo man
yeah man i [ __ ] fill you with that
[ __ ] scream and
you could tell when somebody says
something that it's really not them
you know they're they're putting up this
persona to either appease you
or kind of mirror your your behaviors
yeah and i just looked at him i was like
hey
why are you screaming so much cause i
mean you screamed too i was like yeah in
videos [ __ ] why are you screaming at me
i don't talk like this on a day-to-day
basis yeah and i'm just sitting there
just just really awkward interaction
yeah it's like oh man like i was just
trying to be like you man like i want to
be
you i was like if you want to be me shut
the [ __ ] up like relax relax
those are comedy videos they're in that
three-minute space where i chop up a
bunch of jokes
you're having a conversation with me as
a human being and trust me i know what
it's like to freak
uh freak out when you meet somebody that
you enjoy i'm not saying that doesn't
happen to me
like when i when i've met people that i
liked and i talked about the story where
i met tatiana ali
for the first time yeah i held her hand
for like a solid minute and i
didn't let go because i freaked the [ __ ]
out i freaked out i didn't know what to
do
yeah it was at this club event and it
was super dark and i didn't know who she
was
and then uh my buddy introduced me to
her and i was like yo this this is
tatiana and i
held her hand hey nice to meet you and i
looked at her and i froze
i [ __ ] froze and i held her hand
and she was just smiling still holding
my hand and then kind of saying hey nice
to meet and i
and i just kind of looked at her just
with my mouth open yeah
he got shook i got shook i was like in
my mind i'm like oh [ __ ] like i'm
shaking the hands of tatiana ali yeah
you have any idea how many times
i've masturbated that
that exactly that's your whole thing
right
i have masturbated to you so much and
she shook my hand
and i just i just couldn't believe it so
i understand what it's like to meet
you know somebody that you enjoy or to
be somebody you enjoyed watching so i'm
not any better
but [ __ ] man like just screaming in my
face for like a solid minute
was what did you expect how was i
supposed to feel
you know well that's when you failed to
kind of
be self-aware yeah it's like i was there
yeah it's like
people don't talk like that bro in real
life come on man if they do they're
[ __ ] psychotic yeah
who just yells non-stop in a normal
conversation
yeah and trying to you know talk about
normal things
yeah it's dropping [ __ ] i mean i
cursed a lot too but he was just
i think he said [ __ ] 30 times in 10 in a
10 second span
and just like god man what's going on i
just felt so uncomfortable
i thought he was going to kill me say
hey buddy
i don't really like your nervous energy
right that's making me nervous
i'm gonna have to i'm gonna have to put
you down if you give this up you know
[ __ ] ellen degeneres though like
i when i when i look at that situation
and i hear about all these terrible
stories you know first of all the
uh the work culture which is terrible
and i'm pretty sure there's a ton of
people out there who's
had a terrible work culture and if
that's the case
it doesn't make you you have to you
spend so much of your time at work
and if you have to walk into that
situation every day
i i would just [ __ ] leave and there
was i think there was a story that i
read where somebody
didn't there was some issues like race
issues
and she decided just to leave work she
decided just to quit her job on the spot
which is terrible yeah and i'm not
saying that she has to know everything
about the day-to-day about her company
but if there's a lot of people coming
out talking about like you said her
behavior
and how mean and intimidating she is i
guess which
when you said that i kind of remember
yeah i guess like somebody mentioned
that
something i mean i think she denied it
though she said that
people aren't allowed to look at her in
the eye or something like that
yeah they can't look at her in the eye
or something
and she said that's the most ridiculous
thing that she's ever heard
but i don't know that's kind of specific
hey man some of these celebrities bro
they're on some weird [ __ ] man they're
on some other [ __ ] you know um
i i and i wouldn't put it past them
because their life is
so far from reality yeah you know yeah
it's so far from reality
and what that does to one psyche and and
their perspective on the world
i can only imagine you know what i mean
like
you pretty much have all the no's in the
world turn into yeses
there's nothing you cannot do there's
nothing you cannot get
you know uh there's no man or woman you
cannot lay with
whatever your preference is you know um
so when you have that i mean imagine how
much that
works just kind of your your perspective
on life
and reality in general you know um
so have you ever had like a [ __ ] boss oh
yeah for sure
for sure um i mean i've for me
i'm i'm always a very vocal person and
i'm not i don't shy away
[ __ ] you [ __ ] i don't shy away from
confrontation
so i've definitely got into it you know
with the higher ups
um but it's never a thing of like
it's just me being disrespectful like
nah i'm not gonna do
what you're asking me to do it's not
that type of [ __ ] it has to
like violate my values or
on some level where i deeply disagree
with what's being said or what's being
done or a mixture of both
and then i'll see my piece with it and i
don't
mind or i i never minded risking losing
my job over it
like if that's the case so be it my
whole thing is
i'm talking about this not only for
myself but for everybody else here
to just make sure that this workplace is
a healthy like um
a healthy work culture and a healthy
environment for all the employees
um so yeah i've plenty of times plenty
of times where
you know bump heads and then uh [ __ ] one
time man i almost got into like a fist
fight with a manager
in the middle of the office yeah cause
what do you do um
we got into it was a dude yeah we got
into it
and then he started saying some things
that were more personal attacks
and like what i don't remember exactly
but
[ __ ] your mom yeah
but but something along those lines like
something that
would be more of a personal attack than
it just remaining working business
um and i was getting like extreme
angry and i was like oh if this
[ __ ] keeps at this level
i'm about to bank this [ __ ] i
know but it didn't get there
um but yeah i mean it's it's uh that's
like i said i don't i don't shy from
confrontation so if somebody is uh
stepping on my toes i've only had one
bad boss oh really and
the worst [ __ ] human being ever dude
and i called her mom
that [ __ ] why do you call her my actual
mom
she would boss me around she would say
he's a personally offensive [ __ ]
follow me to my house
there's no such thing as hr with that
[ __ ] bro i didn't have an hr
you know what hr was like my mom would
wear a hat and she was you want to talk
to hr they should
turn ahead backwards she goes welcome to
hr [ __ ]
nobody gives a [ __ ] about what you think
dog i just
hate working at my parents store all the
time i had to work at my parents store
like fridays and saturdays which is the
days you're supposed to have [ __ ] fun
right and my brother never really had to
work at the store because he was the
golden child so my parents
always the firstborn so [ __ ] that [ __ ]
all right
he met i had to work at the store all
the [ __ ] time and i just remember
i remember one time i brought it up and
my mom was like
because my brother was in a lot of
after-school programs which he really
[ __ ] wasn't
because i i had some after-school
programs that i wasn't allowed to go to
but i had to go work at the store
and i told my mom i'm like hey how come
how come my brother's not here why am i
always working
right and then she looks at me and she
literally says that she goes
because you're dumb oh man
you're not special david don't you go
your brother's gonna
your brother's over here studying and
stuff all you do is get in fights you're
dumb what do you what do you need to go
to school for
a week i'm like yeah that's kind of
[ __ ] up man
oh that's hilarious but now i feel you
on that because like
um you know sometimes on weekends too um
you know i'd go help my pops at the
store
and uh like one time um you know he was
in a place in compton
and it would be so funny because like
you see
the same dudes come in throughout the
day
but they're progressively getting more
and more drunk
so the it's the weekend so they're like
hey it's time for some [ __ ] modelo
negro
you know it's time for some cervezas um
and then they start maybe at like 12 p.m
and then they come back in at like three
and then they're like
you know a little bit red and then they
come back in at five they're more red
like they come back in at seven and by
then they're just slurring their words
and i'm like damn dude how many guys are
at your [ __ ] place because
each time they come they're buying like
a 24 pack a 36 pack
and i'm like you are coming back pretty
[ __ ] often
so you see like all these all these
different types of characters who have
their vices
there was this old man who used to come
in every three hours to buy scratchers
and god damn yeah he was super addicted
to it hey yo
yeah uh he he would win sometimes you
know of course
but uh it was very nice so
i i didn't really like look at it like
oh look at this [ __ ] degenerate
hey yo man let me get a few of those i
got so many stories about the most
funniest customers there was this dude
that used to come in all the time
and when i say this he was like a he was
like a crackhead
blind cartoon character it's hard to
describe
okay this is what he looked like yeah
number one i've never seen him not wear
overalls
okay always wore overalls sometimes a
t-shirt under there sometimes not
summer time no t-shirt under there's
overalls i'm not sure he had underwear
but he would always have a [ __ ] stick
and a bag tight at the end of it like a
like a hobo like a hobo cartoon
character what the [ __ ]
he had a glass eye and i think it's
because he either it was glass eye or it
was he had glaucoma but it was like that
milky eye
he would come in and he had some his
tongue was all [ __ ] up uh-huh so i
don't know what it was i think he's
because he would like chew on his tongue
and he was like cracked the [ __ ] out
so he was like a big voice and he was
standing like this so you were
like this and so my dad never had any
problems with people coming into the
store even if they were cracked out or
whatever as long as they weren't going
to steal [ __ ] he was fine right
so this dude comes in and he had his
hobo stick with the uh
with the with the little bag tied at the
end of it i'm gonna just say it's red
just because i think it's cute let's see
like a little red bag
at the end of it and he comes in and my
dad stops him and he tells him hey you
can't come into the store with a stick
because why can't i come in he could
sweat like because i'm
black either you do it you tell me i
can't come in because i'm
black and he started making my dad's
like everybody's black kitchen this is a
black beauty supply store
you know he goes oh so you're going to
call the police i do it for
you opens up the door and he just goes
paul wreath
paulie there's a black man in this
though
just freaking the [ __ ] out i'm not even
exaggerating this is
legit what happened and he did this a
couple of times but he just cracked the
[ __ ] out
one time i [ __ ] you [ __ ] not
damn this is a [ __ ] funny memory by
the way it was
it was in summer i remember it was hot
as [ __ ] and i already saw him
at the mcdonald's across the street that
just opened up at the time
he walked in in a trench coat he hid a
large mcdonald's drink
in the sleeve and i'm there ordering
ordering my food and i see the dude in
his overalls with the [ __ ]
um it's like that greenish brown color
this trench coat it's a hundred
something degrees
in sacramento puts the cup in the sleeve
that he took out of the garbage can
outside just walks in
it fills up his drink as if he bought a
drink as a refill
and you know the workers are looking at
him but they just don't want to deal
with the [ __ ]
he gets the drink and he walks outside
right sorry i saw him there and then
when i'm walking on the way
back with the mcdonald's that i have
there's this
box you know the the filet-o-fish box
yeah right yeah
it's open and there's like a half-eaten
fillet fish in there and i'm
about to walk inside to the store and
there's a car about the park
yeah the [ __ ] crackhead that was at
the mcdonald's was
obviously walked back towards this area
because this is where he kicks it this
phil runs up to the car he goes
stop before the car comes in he grabs
the [ __ ] vallejo fish
off the floor and starts eating it it
just walks off
oh he goes stop
picks it up starts eating it i'm like yo
what the [ __ ] is going on with this dude
that dude was nuts he would he would
habitually on the weekends
in blazing hot sacramento sacramento
gets like 110 degrees 100
203 pretty regularly during the summer
for about a couple of weeks it's pretty
consistent
he he would sit cross-legged like this
put his hands on his knees
sit at the edge of the street and just
start rocking back and forth
like this rocking back and forth for
[ __ ] hours
because this dude yeah didn't have all
his marbles man
yeah double whammy getting getting his
brain fried from cracker acid
and from the weather yeah whatever the
drug is that makes you all [ __ ] crazy
but he just rocking back and forth
yeah hey what's up young blood what you
doing young blood
used to always say that [ __ ] he was
older for sure yeah okay like 50 plus
definitely 50 plus i'm not even sure if
he was like uh if he was homeless or not
because he would have a new ch new like
new changes of clothes and he didn't
really smell
so i don't think he was homeless i think
he lived with somebody or he lived in
some type of crackheads just a crackhead
it was just a crack it just cracked the
[ __ ] out
that young blood yeah speaking of
crackheads man
um this is pretty sad when i saw you
remember the rapper nocturnal
yeah yeah yeah yeah remember remember
when he had like a good buzz going you
know he was [ __ ] with like missy
elliot with dre
you know yeah how about i see this dude
at a [ __ ] quiznos man
with the like this would seem like his
grandma or something and the grandma's
buying him food
but this dude was like [ __ ] skinny
and and like i wouldn't really have
recognized him if if i wasn't into like
you know hip-hop so much
i'm looking you know what kate might
have been with me that day
you know is that [ __ ] nocturnal
it's like yeah i think that's [ __ ]
nocturnal
i guess he just got [ __ ] cracked out
and that's why his music career fell off
you're like drugs yeah i looked into it
afterwards you know
and yeah it was it was the drugs like
and that's that's why he fell off and
i'm like dude
what a [ __ ] shame man you had every
opportunity to be like
that dude in the west coast everybody
was co-signing you know
and then he just got heavy into that
crack man and then uh
now his grandma's buying him quiznos
she's just [ __ ] nuts
and quiznos is the worst
if quiznos came up to me and said hey i
want to sponsor you i'd be like
absolutely not
oh thank you i hate your sandwiches [ __ ]
that place man i
i like their chicken mesquite though let
me tell you something about quiznos
quiznos is one of those people
you think you're so much better than
subway you're the same [ __ ] that's what
i like about subway subway doesn't
pretend to be something that they're not
yeah because it was like well you can
get it toasted [ __ ] you still
subway you're another version of subway
you know what i [ __ ] with still uh
jersey mike's jersey mike is different
yeah jersey mike's first of all
jersey mike's has a sandwich right it's
it's their uh
it has all the meats like roast beef
turkey but also has bacon inside it yeah
i don't know which one that [ __ ] is
but i got that [ __ ] so much it's so good
yeah jersey mike's is legit
and they add their little jardiner in it
too yeah olive oil
and you probably eat like a quarter of a
sandwich just like tiny ass
and i got a large uh mrs vick's
salt and vinegar chips with that and a
large drink oh my god
delicious it is it is i just got some
jersey mics the other day
hey shout out to jersey mike sponsored
if you want to sponsor this podcast
i will do the best ad for you hands down
and we will get everybody to get a
jersey mic sub
specifically the sandwich that i get
it's so good it's really good
yeah now you know i actually held off on
trying jersey mics for the longest time
because
i i just didn't think it was gonna be
good i don't know why it was delicious
yeah it is delicious i tried it actually
for the first time this year
oh no no uh late last year oh you're
[ __ ] you you missed out yeah i i have
been missing out i rec
i realized my mistake when i when i took
a bite into you ever you had arby's
before
yeah i've never had our arby's sandwich
well you're not missing anonymous okay
because there's this arby's in
sacramento that's like in it's like on
flooring roads like
kind of like a hood ass area yeah yeah
and it just looks like [ __ ] it does look
like [ __ ] but you know what
i ate that when i was a kid so that's
why i still have
nostalgia yeah yeah that nostalgic
factor there their curly fries are legit
though because it's seasoned curly fries
they were rated like the best fries you
could get yeah that shit's legit
they're roast beef though more like
roadkill
you know oh damn see yeah
it ain't i don't know what the [ __ ] kind
of roast beef they're using for that
but um i load it up with the rv sauce
and then that's pretty much what i taste
oh yeah yeah um i'm not a big fan of
that [ __ ] though yeah
yeah i don't think i don't think too
many people are like
yo i need some armies right now i know
one dude this dude named alex he comes
out his podcast every night alex [ __ ]
he [ __ ] with arby's he goes arby's is
[ __ ] fire
i'm like no dog you are right never
heard anybody say is fire well that's
what that fool says
i'm telling you something it's [ __ ]
taste buds no i got never got a homie
who hates on arby's like
crazy he calls it garby's because he's
just garbage that's [ __ ] i always
hype it up to him though
he said yo arby's is my [ __ ] it's
so [ __ ] because it gets him so worked
up because he hates it so much
but i don't i don't really [ __ ] with
harvey's like
i can't i don't know i've never ever
looked at an arby's and say i wanted to
eat there all right you know what me and
you we're gonna get someone
maybe man if i throw up i throw up it's
like [ __ ] yoshinoya in the states
yeah in the states is disgusting no man
it's so disgusting japan on a worst day
for their yoshinoya can
is infinitely better than america in its
best day
it's so good it's so good yeah yeah
sukiya beef bowl uh yoshinoya and then
the one that starts with the m what is
it matsuya or
something like that when you're talking
yeah yeah yeah that's the only one i
didn't try but
i actually like sukiya's beef bowl the
best that [ __ ] every time i go to japan
i only eat one meal because i'm trying
to uh try it
like as many different meals as possible
but that i will always get at least
twice
before i leave yeah i just make i just
do beef both myself now that should
it's pretty easy oh really yeah it's
super easy you could you could make you
could make uh
you don't in like [ __ ] five minutes
it's really that easy okay
yeah you're gonna have to teach me the
recipe you'll make it so fast and you
can do
you know your own variations on it
however you like it yeah and i just put
like
right before i cover it up i throw one
little egg and it poaches in there and
then just put it on top
the the beef is as tender though yeah
for sure you said
however long you cook it is going to be
how tender it's going to be okay if you
get rib eye
yeah and then it's super thinly cut like
in the korean supermarket yeah
it's already tender as [ __ ] oh so you're
basically using like the
the shabu meat yeah yeah yeah okay
because that's what they're doing it's
just
we're not butchered so we're not gonna
slice it up just go to the korean market
get that [ __ ] and then you make the
sauce which is just
it's um dashi sugar mutant
uh soy sauce and that's it that's all
that oh no
no ginger for you oh ginger if you
ginger garlic sake whatever you want
yeah and then after that you're pretty
much good to go yeah oh i hate ginger
that was a trick question yeah you were
only jittery
i [ __ ] hate ginger bro really yeah i
do not like it man
it's so good like in like meat like
ginger and garlic yeah
i hate ginger dude i trashed her you're
[ __ ] sick
a korean person doesn't like ginger and
i've never heard that in my life
so like even in kimchi when there's a
piece of ginger and i taste it i'm like
ah
[ __ ] man like it it ruins my video you
know why you don't like it because of
the [ __ ]
cause there's a [ __ ] ton of ginger in
honey true
so what he's talking about i was just
talking to him about this before the
podcast it's this herbal medicine
and it's like asians [ __ ] swear to
god this is like
a drink of the gods you know if you
drink this thing
you're gonna be healthy you're not ever
gonna get any like colds or diseases
like
you become superhuman so my parents used
to [ __ ] try to force feed me this
[ __ ]
and i got so traumatized from it like
even the smell of it would get me to yak
so i yacked all the time on this [ __ ]
you know every time
and and then it's like they know i'm
gonna [ __ ] yak
but then they still get it again and i'm
like why the [ __ ] do you keep
trying to force me to eat cause you
gotta grow more you gotta eat more
i'm like i'll do that you know it's like
the worst herbal medicine on earth
they it sometimes but tree bark is in
there
deer antler like maggot butthole there's
some weird [ __ ] ingredients and they
you know
it's specifically eastern medicine that
you know i mean people swear by it i
mean there is definitely stuff in there
that's used in traditional medicine yeah
right but yeah this is like the raw form
of it dude and they boil it down
yeah black on top of that that makes it
the worst
right it looks like swamp water yeah and
and the smell of it oh my god the whole
house yeah the smell the taste it's
[ __ ] bitter
you know oh god man and one time
i told him this too like i i ate i ate a
meal
and i went to somebody's house who was
like grown these type of herbs
as soon as i smelled it i just yacked i
just yacked on their [ __ ] sidewalk
you know i was like we were talking
about this i i had that thing where if i
see somebody throw up
i throw up immediately if you throw up
in front of me
i'm gonna throw up in your mouth i was
telling this so in sacramento there's
this joint called jj north
and it was a um it sounds like a porn
star's name
it was his buffet spot called jj north
people of sacramento know what's up
that they used to be the dopest buffet
spot before all the asian buffets were
there
and before hometown buffet was there and
that was a spot that my parents would
always take us on a sunday or it would
be like a special meal
right and so we were there and i
remember one time as we were walking out
and we were done eating and i just
stuffed myself with all that fried
chicken and goodness
this kid throws up in front of me and i
look at him and i throw up in front of
him
and so we just yak in front of each
other and then somebody else behind us
saw us yak and that dude yak too so
there was just
there's a yak party so everybody threw
up at the same time in that restaurant
i remember i still remember what my dad
said this fool didn't even feel
apologetic
he just looks at me he goes look at
everybody goes my son is crazy
he just grabs me and then takes me out
like i like i [ __ ] up like i did
something terrible it's like i threw up
because he threw up
what the hell oh man like i don't know
it's something about like other people
with sensitive gag reflexes and like who
throw up
it just cracks me up man i don't know it
just it just tickles my funny bone bad
have you ever seen somebody throw up and
have it come out their nose
it's disgusting i don't know if i've
ever seen somebody that close while
they're throwing up
you know i was holding up the uh one one
of my homegirl's uh
head when she was throwing up and she
was in the bathroom and i had to hold
her [ __ ] hair because all her other
girlfriends were [ __ ] wasted it was
disgusting
she started i wouldn't say her name
she'll get mad
but she she started throwing up and when
she was throwing up she coughed or
sneezed and she went
oh good god she shot out her nose
disgusting i didn't [ __ ] disgusting
absolutely different
disgusting [ __ ] story uh drinking
involved
paul is involved right and uh i won't i
won't name the dude who
uh who got [ __ ] up but he basically
challenged paul i think it was like the
first time he met paul
that's a terrible terrible [ __ ] i told
him i said
don't do it you're gonna [ __ ] regret
it and he's like no i'm gonna go shot
for a shot with him
all right that's you do i know this guy
yeah i'll tell you who it is okay yeah
who the [ __ ] would challenge paul to a
drinking contest
i was like that's your [ __ ] grave
you're digging your own grave right now
he's like nah that's fine it's fine i
was all right so a long story short of
course he gets
[ __ ] up blacked out right and paul's
fine
and then he's like i'm like oh [ __ ] this
was gonna yak right
so we're trying to [ __ ] get him to
the bathroom and then uh mind you this
is a [ __ ] k-town bar
you know what the men's bathroom is like
absolutely [ __ ] disgusting yak stains
diarrhea stains pee stains all over the
[ __ ] toy and it smells
exactly like those things i'm describing
right
he gets the toilet he puts his hand
on the [ __ ] toilet and he's yakking
in it right i'm like oh and i'm trying
to help him out
i'm like oh don't do that though bro
come on man
like and then and then he puts his arms
around
what i'm like oh god dude this is the
forearm wrestling yeah the forearm
resting on him where did he drink
i don't know man i mean it's like
something that wouldn't even faze paul
you know what i mean but paul's a
[ __ ] something's wrong with that guy
paul drinks a lot yeah that guy's uh
i've never seen
anything i've seen paul paul once came
over to our apartment the k-town one
and he drank like a we had sky vodka for
some for some
odd reason uh we drank half of that [ __ ]
no first he drank so i'm not sure if you
were there
but we had a bottle of jameson he and i
just drank it together i because you
know paul and i we're like really close
friends he's like one of my closest
friends yeah we're
we're talking we're chopping it up i
don't know how much i'm drinking
and actually you know the whole bottle
is gone yeah and i just remember
realizing yo we drank this whole bottle
and then
boom it hit me yeah what from what i was
told
i was as drunk and i grabbed the gembe
the african drum and i was just playing
that [ __ ]
wasted as [ __ ] trying to sing r b music
with the jedi drum
they helped me to my room and then i
[ __ ] yeah i didn't know after that
paul drank with everybody else in the
house with his bottle a huge bottle of
sky vodka
and he's everybody got smashed and then
paul was fine he was just awake by
himself no you don't remember that one
time when it was his birthday
and then we were drinking in k-town and
then we went back to your place and then
uh drank more and paul was like [ __ ]
up
like he he was he was basically
stumbling and like hugging everybody
um was that girl uh um i
don't know who he is was that girl
daniella there too yeah yeah yeah i
remember that day
yeah and then so that's the first time
i've seen
paul get that drunk before where he
stumped but he he had a
insane amount of alcohol that night
right
and then we go to mcdonald's afterwards
right
now he's stumbling walking into the
mcdonald's after he has the mc
now first of all not only does he drink
an insane amount of alcohol he eats an
insane amount
yes like three value meals for a meal
he eats that walks out completely normal
hey i'm fine now let's go drink some
what the [ __ ] kind of human being
i remember this [ __ ] yeah because it was
like three a.m it was like four yeah
three or four yeah that's right yeah
yeah oh man damn all these memories are
starting to flood back so back in the
day right
so this is before now this these are
just facts
this is just before a bunch of white
people started coming to [ __ ] k-town
yeah
we used to have a lot of these
underground drinking spots they would be
open until the next morning yeah pretty
much and this is the [ __ ] that me edric
and paul we used to always go to these
spots yeah and you would only be allowed
in if you knew somebody who knew the
spot
but then [ __ ] all these white
bloggers were blogging about it on
tumblr and [ __ ]
and all of a sudden all these businesses
started closing yeah so these were like
these
uh underground speakeasies because in
l.a 2 a.m is when
you can't serve any more alcohol yeah
but we would be up until 6 7 a.m in the
morning so we would go to these
speakeasy spots
but we would drink non-stop oh like
those places would be crazy because like
some of those places
are just what you see in like the movies
you go and you knock and then they open
the door
and then they close it and then you
gotta you gotta be you're going into a
place where it looks completely empty
right it's just an
empty parking lot all the lights are off
so you think it's closed and then you
just gotta know
you just gotta be with it and then you
go in and it's like another life
jam-packed music blasted it's like
where the [ __ ] drinks still popping off
you know everybody was korean in there
yep
the only korean people yep and then they
kind of [ __ ] up when they started
letting white people in there dude
yeah i mean i'm not gonna lie dude the
white people [ __ ] it up for everybody
they really did though i remember i
don't know exactly what it looks like
but i know i only know what it looks
like if i see it at night because that's
the only time you'll see it but there's
graffiti on the wall and everything and
then
that was a spot with the little sliding
door and they would let you in yeah but
that was a spot that me and paul used to
always [ __ ] go to but it's not there
anymore
they shut it down yeah so sad dude yeah
i mean but any time
you just you agree to have a drink with
paul
high chance that he just means
chill yeah he's gonna chill but you it
might be an ordeal in a hurry you know
a hundred percent were you were you
there for my birthday when we went to uh
lock and key
and we drank yeah that's right you were
there yeah i was there yeah i remember
there was a there was a couple of
youtubers that i really don't like that
was there and i think like their
birthday or something was like they're
all along the same lines but um
very vocal that i don't like these human
beings but one of the one of the one of
them came up to me and they was like
hey man i just want to say like yeah i
appreciate you like i love what you're
doing you know
and normal dave i was smashed at this
night right now
when i'm drunk they always say that when
you drink your true personality comes
out
i'm the nicest drunk person you are a
[ __ ]
love bug this guy
likes to hug people he likes to
like laugh and smile and like he gets
very touchy-feely you know
i am the nicest person ever so that's
like who i truly am yeah even these
people i hate their [ __ ] guts yeah
guy came up to me as i just want to say
like her species being super cordial
and i never looked at him i was like
it's okay little buddy and i his hair
was all nicely done i put my head in his
head i scrubbed up his head
i spun him around i slapped him in the
ass i told him to get the [ __ ] out of
here
people are like what the [ __ ] just
happened right okay little buddy
and then um i forgot i think paul told
me too that the other guy i told him i
was like hey man you're doing a good job
i was like keep doing what you're doing
and i was like i said that to him
i must have been drunk for sure because
i [ __ ] hate their guts but when i'm
drunk i'm
sorry i remember i remember that oh that
same night
uh kate was going out with that one
really weird ass girl
yeah that's right dog so when
so khalif was going out with this one
girl at the time
uh i only met her a couple of times but
you know when you look at somebody and
you look into the deep
recesses of their soul you're like this
person is nuts
so when you go into this establishment
lock and key it's a speakeasy and
you have to find the specific doorknob
that opens up the door if you go there
you know what's up
yeah i come out i don't even know who
this girl is
and i see this girl just dancing all up
on the walls touching every single knob
doing like this weird
she started [ __ ] striking a pose like
doing vote voting
and i'm like yo who the [ __ ] is this
crazy ass woman yeah she's doing crazy
[ __ ]
and i'm staring at her and i'm drunk and
i remember this
uh-huh and then i remember clearly was
like oh yeah that's my girl and i'm like
he looked so embarrassed he looked
embarrassed because she was being super
weird
and i guess she does that in social
settings where she acts super like extra
and i was like yo i don't [ __ ] like
this girl when i found out that it was
like the girl that he was talking to i
was like okay
you [ __ ] like hey bro let me let me
tell you man
i took one look at those eyes man there
was a demon inside that [ __ ]
it's hard though i don't even know how
to approach a girl when one of your
friends
when you when your friend goes out with
somebody that you don't like it's always
a very awkward situation
i don't know what to do i don't know
what to say i just have to just deal
with it
yeah i mean you you know you have a a
private conversation with a friend when
the time is right you know what i mean
like
you really love her yeah [ __ ] her huh oh
she's a crazy [ __ ] man let me tell you
something
she turned out to be really crazy too we
all called that [ __ ] yeah
she was nuts yeah you could like
literally see it in her
eyes yeah and it's hard to describe what
it is but
something unnerving you know you kind of
see it and you're like
you know it's kind of one of those makes
you shudder a little bit because i like
crazy people
but they're crazy insane you know
they're crazy in terms of uh they don't
give a [ __ ]
and they kind of they're very honest
they're open they say whatever the [ __ ]
they want yeah however
there's sanity in their eyes you know
you know what i mean you could just tell
this is just a part of their personality
yeah
great example is my buddy joe joe's a
crazy person but he's [ __ ] lovable as
[ __ ] i love that guy to death
for that [ __ ] i mean i don't
even know joe liked that but you know
the few interactions
i had with him the dude is so [ __ ]
random [ __ ] hilarious
you know he's so [ __ ] nuts man
there's like these always this is funny
story too when we're in vegas
he's he's one of the most sporadic human
beings i've ever met in my life
and you know he he's a very
knowledgeable person too because of how
he thinks he's very
he's very calculated but not at the same
time yeah but for example we were in
vegas and
i remember we were gambling and he was
up a lot of [ __ ] money and i think
he was down first and then he was up
like 200 bucks which is great because he
was down a couple of grand or whatever
and then we were playing craps and all
of a sudden like joe
you're uh i remember saying this to him
like bro you're up 200 you're good
he goes that's right no more i'm good i
walk away from the table
all i hear from a distance is this is
his voice going 200.
he bets 200 he loses all of it this was
[ __ ] nuts dude
yeah that i mean again like i don't know
joe personally but that doesn't
surprise me that he would do something
like that crazy dude this guy owns like
a seven-figure company but then he comes
on this podcast and talks about a story
where he ate out a hooker
my god why would you do that
he is the only human being that i know
that would give
service to somebody that he's supposed
to get service for oh
i mean not only that but dude come on
man
like come on man how many how many dicks
been in and out of that
he didn't you know he said he's like he
said he had this animal urge
that he can't help but satisfy when it
needs to happen
and then he ate out a hooker oh dude
that's foul man
that's joe dude that's well more power
to him
he's still living and thriving yeah he's
still
still doing what he's doing it's a
special kind of animal
special kind of breed man
well guys that wraps up this episode of
the genius brain podcast
uh make sure that you check out the
podcast every thursdays and sundays we
just talking [ __ ]
trying to keep you company on your
everyday stuff you can find edric
on instagram at ed2 also you can find
that secret society where you guys can
cop the clothing in the gear
make sure you guys check that [ __ ] out
and we will see you all next time all
right joe
peace peace
you